المشهد اليومي ومسلسل الجرائم التي
يرتكبها الاحتلال في الضفه الغربيه هنا من
مدينه نابلس حيث اقتحم الاحتلال مخيم
بلاطه بعشرات الاليات العسكريه تابعها
تعزيزات عسكريه اسرائيليه الى المنطقه
برفقه جرافات حاصر المخيم من كافه المحاور
وصلت مركبه الى هذا الطريق فقام الاحتلال
بقصفها بشكل مباشر ما ادى الى
يعني على الاقل هناك عدد من الشه داء في
داخل هذه المركبه هنا نتحدث عن مكان
العمليه ومكان استهداف هذه المركبه حيث
تقوم طواقم الدفاع المدني وطواقم الاسعاف
ب يعني محاوله انتشال او البحث عن من تبقى
في هذه المنطقه داخل المركبه تم اخراج
يعني نصف جثمان فيما بقي النصف الاخر في
المركبه التي صادرها الاحتلال نتحدث معهد
شهود العيان هنا في المنطقه وما جرى داخل
يعني خلال ساعات الليل من استهداف للمركبه
تفضل اي بحوالي الساعتين من الان احنا
متواجدين في
البيت سمعنا صوت انفجار ضخم هز الشارع
نايه توجهت الى شرفه المنزل لارى ماذا
يحدث فاذا بسياره تحترق تمام على ما يبدو
تم استهدافها بصاروخ من طائره مسيره او ما
شابه بعد ثلاث دقائق
من ثلاث دقائق الى خمس
دقائق فاذا بجيش الاحتلال يدفع بتعزيزات
عسكريه جبات ومسحوبه بجرافك ايضا تم اخماد
الحريق حريق
السياره بواسطه الجرافه
العسكريه وبعد ذلك تم انتشال جثمانين على
ما يبدو لشهداء رحمه الله
عليهم وبعد بعد ذلك بقي الجيش متواجد
بحدود النصف ساعه كقوه راجله تمام
مشاء على الارض يبحثون
عن يعني لا نعلم عن عن ماذا يبحثون وبعد
ذلك تم
انسحابهم شكرا الك الك على هذه التفاصيل
اذا ضمن مسلسل الجرائم اليوميه التي
ينتهجها الاحتلال هذا المشهد والمجزر
الجديده التي ينفذها الاحتلال في الضفه
الغربيه بالتزامن مع ذلك هنا اقتحامات
متواصله طوال الليل في مدن الضفه الغربيه
المحتله من محيط مخيم بلاطه لي جعار
الجزيره